[Musique]
voici sirius 1 le space x des yvelines
un lanceur spatial réutilisable conçu
par la start-up sirius paye service is
une technologie en cours de
développement dans le laboratoire de
cette entreprise basée aux loges en
josas c'est un lanceur qui fait environ
20 mètres de haut un diamètre dans la
rue de 7 mètres et qui pèsera à 20
tonnes au décollage on voit ici le
premier étage qui est un étage qui
comporte neuf moteurs
c'est un danseur qui fonctionne à
l'oxygène liquide et au méthane est au
dessus on peut voir la coiffe et c'est à
cet endroit que seront accommodés les
satellites qui seront lancées par ce
lanceur en ce moment sont en train de
tester la plaque d'injection de ce
moteur à eau sous pression sur le banc
d'essai qui est situé juste derrière moi
[Musique]
ce banc d'essai permet de tester la
plaque d'injection du moteur une
expérience réalisée avec de l'eau et de
l'air comprimé à haute pression sirius
paye service is a été créée en avril
2020 aujourd'hui 35 collaborateurs
composent cette société une levée de
fonds de 3 millions d'euros en 2021 pour
pouvoir développer une gamme de trois
lanceurs spatiaux s'élancèrent va servir
à mener des charges utiles des thés
satellite comprise entre 1 et 500 kg
dans des orbites différentes donc
désormais comprise entre 2 700 km de la
société a été à deux valeurs clés on a
pour le but de proposer deux lanceurs
peu cher on adéquation avec le marché et
aussi des lanceurs 100% réutilisables
interne pour diminuer l'empreinte
carbone majoritairement dans un premier
temps on se concentre sur marché
européen et dans un second temps va lire
rapidement vers le marché - marché aux
états unis et côté chine aussi asie
avec le recrutement de 20 personnes
supplémentaires dans les six prochains
mois l'objectif est fixé à 100
collaborateurs fin 2022 une usine de
production devrait ouvrir au deuxième
semestre 2022 sur le plateau de saclay
le premier vol d'un lanceur spatial
sirius est prévue début 2011 25 depuis
le centre spatial de kourou en guyane